[موسيقى]
اذا لماذا تم اعتقالك في ليبيا
هنا في العاصمه الليبيه وبينما كانت
الانظار موجهه الى الحرب على طرابلس
حدث اخر كان لافتا ومثيرا
اعتقال الشخصيه الروسيه المثيره للجدل
مكسيم شوقالي ومساعده في ظروف غامضه جنوب
طرابلس غموض شاب القصه في كل مراحلها
وصولا الى الافراج عنهما واسئله كثيره
بقيت بلا اجابات حول تداعيات هذه الحادثه
والدور الروسي في ليبيا سياسيا وعسكريا
والمخفي فيه
[موسيقى]
العاشر من كانون الاول ديسمبر عام 2020
توفق هذه اللقطات التي تبث لاول مره لحظات
تسليم معتقلين روسيين الى سلطات بلادهما
من قبل السلطات الليبيه بطرابلس هم مكسيم
شوقالي وسامر سيفان
عمليه التسليم تمت في مطار معيتيجا ويظهر
في هذه اللقطات ايفان
كبير المستشارين باداره الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا في وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
هذه اللحظات انهت الفصل الاخيره من قصه
جدليه لكن كثيرا من فصولها بقيت غامضه
ومخفيه
في الرابع من ابريل نيسان عام 2019
شنت قوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
عمليه عسكريه اسمتها عمليه تحرير طرابلس
لقد
دقتوا كما عهدناكم بخطواتها بالله
بينما كانت تسيطر على العاصمه الليبيه
القوات التابعه لحكومه الوفاق والتي كان
يراسها حينها فايز السراج
شهور من القصف والاشتباكات ومعارك الكر
والفرد
[موسيقى]
هنا في محور صلاح الدين كانت الجبهه
مشتعله وتسربت معلومه عن اعتقال روسيين
وفرار رجل ثالث كان يرافقهما
منذ اللحظات الاولى كان واضحا ان الشخصيه
التي تم اعتقالها ليست عاديه وان
المسؤوليه المترتبه على اعتقالها ستكون
كبيره
وتتعدى الميدان الليبي الى ما يبدو جزءا
من صراع سياسي بين دول خارجيه
سيد خالد المشرف في 17 مايو 2019
تم اعتقال مكسيم شوجالي واحد مساعديه في
طرابلس ما تفاصيل ما جرى جاءت معلومات
مخابراتيه من دوله اجنبيه
لوزاره الداخليه ولمكتب النائب العام من
هي الدوله الارجح ان هي امريكا بناء عليها
تم
مهاجمه الموقع اللي كانوا موجودين فيه
واعتقالهم طبعا انا في تلك الفتره كانت
بعد روسيا الى هذه الفتره لم تتدخل لصالح
صالح يفتر لم تكن فاجنر على الارض لم تكن
فاجنر على الارض اذا تلك اللحظه يعني
انت كنت وزير الداخليه اثناء الاعتقال
لماذا تم اعتقاله الحقيقه اللي هو تم
انتقالها مكتب النائب العام ومكتب النائب
العام هو لديه كامل معلومات مكانش عندي
هنا في داخليه يعني معلومات عليه
تحركات غاليه مكتب النائب العام كان ليها
وهو اللي امر بالقبض عليهم يعني بالنسبه
انت كنت شخصيه مركزيه في الحكومه الم يعرض
عليكم النائب العام النائب العام من
صلاحياتها لحد ينفذ على طول ومصالحيات
القانونيه ايضا يستطيع ان يامر اي اي
اداره في وزاره الداخليه او اي قوه في
وزاره الداخليه تنفذ القبض مباشره حتى
بدون علم وزير الداخليه هذه الصلاحيات
مكتب النائب يعني اعتقل وافرج عنه دون
معرفتكم لماذا تم اعتقاله ولماذا تم
الافراج عنه لا ليست لدي معلومات كامله
بالنسبه الى معلومات يعني هي استقيها من
هنا او هناك
هناك من يقول استاذ عبد الرزاق ان مصدر
المعلومه التي قادت الى اعتقال شوجالي
ومرافقه او المترجم الذي كان معه كانت
امريكيه المصدر ما حقيقه هذه المعلومه وهل
توثقتم منها خلال بحثكم
في الاطار العام نحن تاكدنا من هذه
المعلومه من مصدرين مصدر امني ومصدر عتلي
كلاهما
يعني نتكلم على يعني
اشخاص مسؤولين في الدوله
تواصلنا معهم تحافظ على ذكر اسم يعني كنا
في طرابلس هنا في طرابلس
واكدوا لنا هذه المعلومه ان المصدر هو من
جهه امريكيه ما هي التفاصيل التفاصيل هي
بعد هجوم حفتر على على طرابلس في شهر
اربعه 2019 بعد تقريب باسبوعين
تصل ضابط الاتصال الامريكي اللي كان موجود
في
في منطقه جنزور هنا في طرابلس ايه لمن
اعطيت هذه المعلومه لوزاره الداخليه في
حكومه السراج هذاك كان لذاك السيد الوزير
فتحي بشار وهل تاكدتم من مصدر هذه
المعلومه نعم صحيح يعني
التعاون الاستخباراتي الامريكي الليبي هو
اللي افضى في نتيجه في نهايه المطاف الى
القبر على شكر هناك ايضا من قال انه
الاعتقال تم بناء على معلومات تم تزويدها
من طرف خارجي والاشاره الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
كامل الماء لم اطلع على ملف
التباين السياسي حول تبني اعتقال شوقالي
وما قد يتبعه من مسؤوليات يشيء باهميه
الرجل المعتقل ودوره
مكسيم شوغالي الرجل الغامض والذي تحوم
حوله كثير من الشبهات ماكسيما
عرفه الاعلام الرسمي الروسي بعد اعتقاله
بانه عالم اجتماع
وتم انتاج فيلمين سينمائيين روسيين يحكيان
قصه اعتقاله في ليبيا
الحكم بالاعدام
[موسيقى]
باحث امجاسوس تسائلت صحيفه ذا وول ستريت
جورنال ووصفت الصحيفه الامريكيه شوقالي
بانه ساعد في نشر القوه الناعمه الروسيه
في الاماكن التي يتراجع فيها النفوذ
الامريكي وقد تم رصد زياره اجراها الرجل
مؤخرا الى افغانستان بعد الانسحاب
الامريكي منها توثق هذه الصور جانبا من
زياره شوقالي الى كابول بعد سيطره حركه
طالبان على السلطه
[موسيقى]
تمكنا من الوصول الى مكسيم شوقالي واجراء
مقابله معه في مدينه سان بطرسبورغ وافق
على اجراء المقابله مع تحفظه على الخوض في
كثير من التفاصيل
شكرا لكم على هذا اللقاء مع قناه الجزيره
سيد مكسيم شوقالي اسمك مثير للجدل هناك من
يربطه بادوار سياسيه وامنيه وعسكريه لصالح
روسيا خارج الحدود كيف ترد على ذلك
انا رئيس صندوق حمايه القيم الوطنيه
وصندوقنا يساعد الكثير من الناس في روسيا
وخارجها نحن نجني المستثمرين والممولين
لمساعد الكثير من الناس الذين يمرون بظروف
صعبه لست رجلا عسكريا
لقته في الجيش اخر مره بين عامي 84 و86 في
جيش الاتحاد السوفيتي وهي دوله مختلفه
تماما انا لست مسؤولا او نائبا وليس لي اي
علاقه بالقوات الخاصه او القوات المسلحه
اذا لماذا تم اعتقالك في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لاقامه في ليبيا فقد كنت في السجن
في ظروف صعبه لمده عام وثمانيه اشهر حين
صادروا هواتفي مني وجميع مقتنياتي في
منزلي لم يكن هناك احد سوايا والمترجم فقط
لم يكن هناك اسلحه من اي نوع انا دخلت
ليبيا بتاشيره رسميه لم يتم توجيه اي
اتهام ضدي بشكل واضح
ولاي اتهام وما يسمى بالقضاه قاموا بتاجيل
جلسات المحاكمه باستمرار واجراء تحقيقات
اضافيه ولم يكن هناك ما يستدعي التحقيق
لذلك لا اريد مناقشه ظروف احتجازي لدي ما
اقوله لكنني لا اريد في هذه المقابله
الخوض في ذلك الشان انه متاكد من ان هذا
الموقف قد تم توجيهه ودعمه من الخارج وانا
وانتم يجب علينا تجاوزه
قوه الرضع الخاصه او جهاز الردع القوه
العسكريه والامنيه التي نفذت عمليه القبض
على شقال ورفقه وهي التي اشرفت على سجنه
والتحقيق معه بالتنسيق مع النيابه العامه
الليبيه
السلام عليكم
موعد
[تصفيق]
تحفظ جهاز الردعي على ظهور اي من قياداته
امام الكاميرا لكنه وافق على الافراج لاول
مره عن مواد حصريه توثق جانبا مهما ومثيرا
من قصه شوقالي وفريقه
هنا في هذا الموقع جنوب العاصمه طرابلس
تمت مداهمه منزل كان يسكنه شوغالي برفقه
سامر سعيفان مع اخرين كانوا يترددون
عليهما
مفتاح
هذه اللقطات الحصريه التي تبث لاول مره
عمليه المداهمه والاعتقال التي تمت في
السابعه عشر من مايو ايار عام 2019
اي حاجه اعطوني اي حاجه خليني
تمكن جهاز الردع من الاحتفاظ بشغالي في
سجن معيتيجا بطرابلس
رغم المعارك الضاريه التي دارت على بعد
كيلومترات قليله من السجن وفي ظل القصف
المستمر تم التحقيق معه لاشهر لمعرفه
حقيقه دور الفريق الروسي في الاراضي
الليبيه
يوسف المليان هو المترجم الذي تمت
الاستعانه به في التحقيق مع شوغالي وهو
ضابط سابق وكان مطلعا على ملف العلاقات
الليبيه الروسيه
استاذ يوسف هل لك ان تعود لنا بالذكرى الى
اول لقاء مع شوجان لداخل السجن كان يعني
لقاء طبعا كسجين متى كان بالضبط كان بدايه
بعد ثلاث شهور تقريبا من بدايه ثمانيه
طبعا كانت الفتره الاحداث والحرب كان اول
لقاء
تواصلوا معي جهاز الردع بخصوص ترجمه ما
كنتش عارف انا موضوع في شوجالي ولا مطلوب
للترجمه قلت له موجود انا حاضر
فكان معصوب العينين
دخل انا دخلته من الباب
فكلمته بالروسيه يعني شو حكيت والله انك
قلت لجمله كانت هي يعني قريبه لقلبها يعني
بيقولوا نبري واي يعني ما تشيلش هم
مفهومنا احنا كل شيء كويس
حاولت يعني نبعث في نفس الطمانين فكان كان
مصدوم هو قال انت منه يعني
انت منين لان ليبيا انت مش ليبي وبدات
نتعامل معاه يعني مبدا انساني بحكم انك
انت بتهيا بمتهم
لتحقيق يعني
فكانت الكلمه هذه وقعت على قلبها وقع يعني
اعطتها انطباعه كويس واستريح يعني وحاولت
يعني نلفت انتباه انه ياخذوا حال باعتبار
بحكم اهميتك ما هي الاشارات التي
اعطتك انه رجل مهم طبعا الاشارات كلهم
المنتسبين مهام الخاصه لازم يوضع في جسمها
اثر معين او علامه داله في حاله فقدانه في
احد المهام او وجود احد اطرافها
فالوشم هذا يكون علامه تعريفه يعني ان
الشخص هذا خلاص
وهذا الوشم كان على جسده موجود على جسم شو
قال كان عنده وشم مع اليسار وشم في الصدر
فكانت هذه العلامات الداله يعني وهذه كانت
الاشاره الحاسبه بنسبه لك انه هو من من
يعني ليس بالشخص العادي
يعني مش مواطن عادي لا هذا مار بمرحله
تدريب شاقه جدا ومهما تستخدمت معها من
اساليب الضرب ومن اساليب العنف مش حيتجاوب
معك فهذا حيكون لي مدخل اخر يعني في
التحقيق يعني مدخل غير الضرب وغير السليب
التقليديه وللامانه يعني الحمد لله
المجهود اللي بدلوه ضباط التحقيق ومجهود
هنا معاهم في الترجمه يعني قدرنا
نفهم القصه بالكامل يعني
[موسيقى]
حصلنا على نسخه حصريه مسربه من مذكره
نيابه العامه الليبيه في قضيه شوقالي
وفريقه
بحسب المذكره فان مكسيم شوقالي نشط مع
اخرين بالعمل على الاراضي الليبيه ضمن
فريق الروسي واطلع بمهام متعدده ضم هذا
الفريق الى جانب شوغالي كلا من سامر
سعيفان يحمل الجنسيات الروسيه والاردنيه
والبروفيه وهو في الاصل طبيب جراح وكان
المترجم المرافق لشوجالي واعتقل معه
يحمل الجنسيتين الروسيه والسوريه وقد غادر
الاراضي الليبيه باتجاه تونس قبل ايام من
القبض على شجعله
قسطنطين هو احد مؤسسي حركه شباب روسيا
الموحده اسند اليه عمل استخبارته ويقوم
بتتبع الانتخابات خارج روسيا وقد حضر الى
ليبيا قبل وصول مكسيم شوغالي وكان يتردد
عليها بصفه دائمه خلال السنوات الاخيره
ويزور مدنا ومناطق مختلفه جميع اعضاء هذا
الفريق دخلوا بتاشيرات رسميه صادره عن
جهات مختلفه لكن اللافته انهم دخلوا تحت
غطاءات مختلفه
[موسيقى]
اسم تكرر بشكل لافت في محضر النيابه
العامه الليبيه وقد اشير اليه بعده اسماء
من بينها بيج بوس
يفقين يوصف بانه احد اكبر صناع القرار في
المطبخ الروسي وعلى صله بادوار روسيه
متعدده الازرع في الخارج ارتبط اسمه بشكل
مباشر في تاسيس مجموعه فاجنر
بعد سنوات من الغموض
ظهر الرجل بشكل لافت خلال الاشهر الاخيره
يقود علنا مجموعات فاجنر العسكريه في
القتال داخل اوكرانيا ويتحدث باسمها
ما هي علاقتك
[موسيقى]
كونه مشارك في بعض مشاريع صندوقنا لا
استطيع ان اجيبكم عما يدعمهم في اوشن مثل
بعض المشاريع الخاصه التي لا تشارك فيها
قطعا القوات المسلحه فهذه اعماله الخاصه
اعرف كشخص محترم ويحترم مصالح بلادنا
والبلدان الاخرى
ليس مؤسسا ولا اداريا في مؤسستي كل
القرارات التي اتخذها في هذه المؤسسه
مستقله تماما
[موسيقى]
بعد عمليه اعتقال شوقالي ومترجمه جرت في
المراحل الاولى محاولات روسيه حديثه في
الكواليس للمطالبه بالافراج عنهما
يعني كمحاوله التوسط لانهاء المشكله بدون
ضجه تتواصل معي
الطباخ نفسه
شخصيا شخصيا
وبعدين نسربوا جزء من هذه المكالمه هما
ونحن مستعدون لبذل كل جهودنا انا اريد ان
اطمنكم اولا هم اخبارهم جيده يعاملوا
معامله جيده ونحن لن نصعد في موضوعهم اي
نوع من التصعيد الاعلامي او غير ذلك ولهذا
سنسعى الى حل الامر بطرق وديه في روسيا لا
نقبل بالابتزاز انتم تطلبون لقاء مع
القياده العليا لروسيا بينما الصندوق
حمايه القيم الشعبيه هو صندوق
عام قالوا في تلك الفتره تسريب مع صحفي لم
تكن مع صحفي
مترجم
حرفها يعني هي ما كانش يتكلم بنفس
الصحيح بروجين كان يتكلم بلهجه منفعل ماذا
قال لكم
ان هؤلاء
لديهم تشير الدخول الى ليبيا بشكل رسمي
وهم مركز بحثي وبالتالي نحن هذا نعتبر
اعتداء على مواطنينا انتم ما عندكمش ادله
قطعيه عليهم انهم ارتكبوا اعمال مخالفه
ويجب اطلاق سراحهم فورا انا قلت له هؤلاء
تدخلوا في انتخابات بلديه محليه
وهناك نشاط ربما يصنف انه نشاط معالي لكن
نحن لا نسعى الى الى توتر الاجواء نريد ان
نعالج الموضوع بهدوء لكن ايضا انتم السيد
رئيس الوزراء طلب زياره وان يلتقي وفي تلك
الفتره المجلس الرئاسي يعني وان يلتقي
بالرئيس وغير كذا
فهما غضبوا من هذا الكلام وقالوا هذا
يعتبر ابتزاز
هذا الرساله وبالتالي هو نحن سنعتبرهم
توفوا
قتلوا قتلوا ونعتبره في اعداد الموتى
وسوف يعني نعالج الموضوع بطريقتنا هذا ادى
الى تدخل في هذه هناك من يقول ان تدخل جاء
بعد اعتقال شوجالي هل هذا واقع لا لا
اعتقد ذلك يعني
نحن زدنا معلومات يعني
من بدايه الحرب عن تواجد روسي كان في
البدايه في راس
راس مالوف وبعدين قبل اعتقال قبل اعتقال
اعتقال
بين المكالمه والتدخل كم اقل من اسبوع هل
جرى اي اتصال اخر مع لا
وعندما فهمت انه عندما قال لك نعتبرهم قد
توفوا قتله هل كان ذلك مؤشرا انهم سوف
يدخلون عسكريا
[موسيقى]
فشل المحاولات السياسيه برز بشكل علني
مشاركه قوات فاجنر الروسيه في معركه
طرابلس وهي قوات مرتزقه الروسيه مثيره
للجدل ذا عصيتها في السنوات الاخيره
لضلوعها في اعمال حربيه ذات صله مباشره
بالدوله الروسيه في ميادين مختلفه مثل
سوريا ومالي ومؤخرا في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كان لدخول قوات فاجنر دور مفصلي في
المعركه التي يشنها خليفه حفتر على طرابلس
وبدا ان الطرفين يصطفان في خندق واحد
السياسيين الليبيان
وعبد الرزاق العراضي عمل على اصدار كتاب
يوثق تفاصيل التدخل الروسي في ليبيا
وفي الحقيقه عندما بدانا في الكتاب كان
عندنا
افتراض بان
الفاجنر دخلوا
من بوابه حفت لمساعده حفتر في عدوانها
لطارب للسيطره على طرابلس
ثم فجئنا بان هذا المعطى غير صحيح وهو ان
بالفعل هم الروس تسربوا الى المنطقه
الشرقيه من خلال حاجه حفتر لتدريب قواته
لكن تسرب
جاء لاحقا عندما تم القبض على شوجالي
دخلوا الى
جنوب طرابلس وشاركوا في القتال في مرحله
لاحقه حتى الحرب تغيرت في طرابلس بعد دخول
[موسيقى]
هذه المنطقه عمليا كان فيها قوات المنطقه
هذه اخر منطقه كانت في المنزل هذا كان
عنده من المنزل هذا اخر منطقه وصلوا فيها
في التقدم
تم الربط بين اعتقالك والتدخل المباشر
لقوات فاجنر في الهجوم على طرابلس ما هي
علاقتك سيد مكسيم
الان كل مواطن روسي موجود خارج روسيا
ويشارك على سبيل المثال في عمليات عسكريه
او تدريب واما الى ذلك يسمونه فاجنر
نيكي
اشبه بعلامه تجاريه لجميع العسكريين
والاشخاص الموجودين في الخارج والذين
يمارسون على سبيل المثال اي نشاط قانوني
على ارض دول اخرى
انا شخصيا لست رجلا عسكريا ولا انتمي الى
اي تنظيمات عسكريه ويمكنني القول ان هذا
نوع من الخرافه
[موسيقى]
اشتد القصف على طرابلس في محاور مختلفه
وبدا ان الروس يبحثون عن دليل حياه بخصوص
مواطنيهم بعد خمسه اشهر من تضارب
المعلومات تم تصوير شريط فيديو يثبت ان
مكسيم شوقالي وسامر سعيفان على قيد الحياه
[موسيقى]
الرجل الذي نقل الشريط من طرابلس الى
سفاره روسيا في العاصمه التونسيه هو يوسف
المليان
قمنا بالتصوير شريط لي ورفعتني للسفاره
الروسيه في تونس تواصلنا مع مندوب منهم
باليد اخذتهم باليد شخصيا
وقست انا وابن شخصيا يعني
2019 شهر اكتوبر 2019 2019 قام بمجهود
كويس في في تخفيف الضغط على على العاصمه
طرابلس واستطعنا ايقاف الطيران لمده 25
يوم وقاف حتى تقدم الفاق بسبب هذا بسبب
هذا الافصاح يعني
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار التطورات العسكريه والتجاذبات
السياسيه بدا افق الوسطات مسدودا بين
الجانبين في ظل تطورات ميدانيه
تكبدت فيها القوات المهاجمه لترابلس خسائر
جسيمه مع تدخل عسكري تركي لصالح حكومه
الوفاق
ووجدنا ان ما يسمى بحكومه الوفاق الوطني
في طرابلس يراسها ارهابيون من داعش
والقاعده والاخوان المسلمين
اما في روسيا فقد نشط الاعلام الروسي في
انتاج اعمال سينمائيه واعلاميه لحشد
التعاطف مع شوجال ورفقه والترويج لفرضيه
اعتقال عالمي اجتماع الروسيين من قبل من
وصفتهم بالارهابيين في طرابلس
[موسيقى]
في هذا التحقيق تمكن ما خفي اعظم من
الحصول على ملفات سريه تضم مئات الوثائق
والتقارير وعشرات المقاطع المصوره التي
كانت في اجهزه شقال الخاصه وتمت مصادرتها
يوم اعتقاله ويتم الكشف عن تفاصيلها لاول
مره
[موسيقى]
تكشف هذه الملفات السريه ما خفي من دور
الفريق الروسي والمرتبطين به في المشهد
الليبي وخارجها
مشروع ليبيا الغد
لان في عدد من الفيديوهات والصور وثق
الفريق الروسي تنقلاته في مناطق مختلفه من
ليبيا تبين اللقطات انهم كانوا يرصدون
ويراقبون بشكل يومي
لا لا لا هذا مصاري طرابلس الرئيسي هذا
كان قاعد
في الجنوب
بومبا
على الشمال هذه الجزيره هذا المجمع الصحي
زاويه الدهماني
[موسيقى]
هذه تقارير سريه ترصد الوضع الميدانيه
والعسكريه في ليبيا كان يكتبها شوقالي
بشكل مفصل ويومي وينقل الى موسكو اخبار
جبهات القتال والمواقع الحساسه ويشرح
المستجدات بدقه
لكن ابرز المهام التي وثقها شوقالي في
تقاريره هي سلسله لقاءات اجراها الفريق
الروسي مع سيف الاسلام القذافي المتواري
عن الانظار منذ سنوات
بهدف دعمه وتهيئته للعوده للمشهد السياسي
وخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
ثلاث لقاءات سريه مع سيف الاسلام وثقها
مكسيم شجالي في تقاريره
[موسيقى]
حضر اللقاء الاول قسطنطين جيروسكوب الذي
قدم مكسيم شوقالي الى سيف القذافي وقد تم
اللقاء في الزنتان عن طريق مرافق لسيف
يدعى احمد العجمي اللقاء الثاني جرى بحضور
كل من شوجالي ومترجمه سامر سعيفان وايضا
احمد العجمي
بينما حضر اللقاء الثالث الكسندر بروكو
فيف الى جانب مكسيم شوقالي وسامر سعيفان
[موسيقى]
ولكن في ملف القضيه تم توجيه التهمه اليك
بمحاوله التدخل في الانتخابات والتاثير
على المشهد السياسي في ليبيا والدليل
لقاءاتك المتكرره والسريه مع سيف الاسلام
القذافي
لقد سالوني لماذا التقيت بسيف الاسلام
حسنا سيف الاسلام القذافي لم يكن معتقلا
حينها لقد كان حرا ويتحرك بكل حريه
دراسه الوضع هي مجرد دراسه اما تاثير على
الانتخابات يكون في استثمار الاموال في
احد المرشحين
والتاثير على بعض المجموعات للتصويت
لصالحه ترك كله لم يحدث وهذا ما لم يتم
اثباته ولم يحاول احد الاثباته يمكنكم
اخبار مشاهدي برنامجكم انه لم تكن هناك اي
اتهامات تثبت انتهاك القوانين الليبيه
احتجاج شخص بسبب لقاء مواطن ليبي حر طليق
حتى لو كان له ماض معين سواء كان اجراميا
ام لا اعتقد ان هذا خطا لا يمكن القاء
القبض على شخص الا اذا انتهك قانونا معين
بخلاف حديثه لنا قال شوقالي في افادته
خلال التحقيقات بانه تحصل على تاشيره
الدخول الى ليبيا بمساعده احدى الشركات
المحليه
وانما تم تدوينه بالدعوه ليس مطابقا لما
حضر من اجله
وافاد بانه كلف باعمال تحر يجب ان تنتهي
قبل موعد انعقاد مؤتمر اقدامس والذي كان
من المفترض ان تحدد نتائجه موعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الليبيه
ملف سري في جهاز شوجالي كان بعنوان تقرير
عن الاجتماع مع سيف الاسلام القذافي
بتاريخ الثالث من ابريل نيسان عام 2019
عقد هذا الاجتماع في بيت بمنطقه الزندان
واستمر ما يقارب الساعتين
يصفالي في تقريره سلوك سيف الاسلام بانه
يظهر بوضوح علامات النرجسيه وانه مقتنع
انه بمجرد ظهوره امام العالم فان معظم
الناس سيدعمونه على الفور وسينتقل اتباع
حفتر اليه
ويضيف شوغالي ان سيف يعد حفتر التهديد
الرئيسي له وذلك على عكس انصاره الذين
يرون ان الاخوان المسلمين هم التهديد
الرئيسي
كما انه يتفهم القضايا السياسيه ومن السهل
مناقشتها معها ولكن عند الحديث عن المسائل
التكنولوجيه والهيكليه فانه يظهر سوء فهم
كبيرا لهذه النقاط ولا يدركها بالشكل
المناسب
بكتابه استنتاج العمل مع سيف الاسلام
يحتاج لحضور دائم حيث لا يكفي اجتماع واحد
في الاسبوع وهو جاهز لذلك
روسيا عندها مصالح وكانت تشتغل كالاتي
كانت تراهن من ناحيه السياسيه على سيف
القذافي وتوظف من الناحيه العسكريه حفتر
واشتغلت
بهذا الشكل طبعا هناك تفاصيل كثيره كشفت
عنها مذكره التحقيقات للنيابه العامه
والتي قامت بجهد عظيم في هذا السياق
هذه المذكرات تكشف بجلاله ووضوحا معلومات
مثيره عن التغلغل الروسي في ليبيا وعن دور
الفاغنر
سالوني لماذا يوجد في منزل نسخ مطبوعه من
اوراق الانتخابات البلديه لكن معذره انا
باحث ويمكنكم انتم ايضا ببساطه ان تجدها
على الانترنت نحن لم نذهب ولم نقم بزياره
اي مركز اقتراع انا لم اقابل اي مرشح
وبذلك لم اؤثر على الانتخابات
تقارير ومراسلات الشوجان السريه وثقت
تفاصيل مثيره
اجتماعات متكرره بزعماء قبائل مقربه من
سيف القذافي في مناطق مختلفه
وتقارير مفصله حول الانتخابات البلديه
الليبيه التي جرت عام 2019
وكيفيه التاثير فيها ودعم فوز شخصيات
مقربه من سيف الاسلام والمشروع السياسي
الذي ترعه روسيا
كما ضمت الملفات استطلاعات راي الروسيه
تثبت ان التحضير للعمل على ملف الانتخابات
الليبيه بدا مبكرا عام 2018
واراد القائمون على هذا الملف حينها تمرير
اسم سيف الاسلام القذافي بين قائمه
المرشحين المحتملين للرئاسه
وجزت نبض الشارع الليبي في الحنين والعوده
الى نظام القذافي
كانت
عمليه ممنهجه وعمليه مرتبطه
بدراسات واستطلاعات
وحول ملفات حساسه وحيويه في ليبيا كان
الغرض منها استخدام هذه المعلومات
لاختراق
الامن الوطني كان كل هذا يوظف بشكل ذكي
ومنهج من ناحيه لتوظيفه لمشروع سيف وتقديم
سيف بانه الرجل المنقذ في ليبيا وايضا من
خلال التلاعب بالمعلومات داخل مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي والفيسبوك وسوشيال
ميديا والقنوات الفضائيه
لخدمه الاخراج الاستراتيجيه الروسيه في
ليبيا
التحقيقات والوثائق السريه التي تم الحصول
عليها من اجهزه شوقالي كشفت عن اداره
الفريق الروسي لصفحات الليبيه باللغه
العربيه عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
للتاثير على الراي العام الليبيه باختلاف
شرائحه ومناطقه
في هذا الملف اعد شوقالي وفريقه برنامج
الحمله الانتخابيه لسيف الاسلام القذافي
بما فيه الشعارات المقترحه للحمله
المعلومات والشواهد تكشف ان مكسيم شوغالي
يشكل حلقه في سلسله متصله ترتبط مع ارفع
مراكز صنع القرار في موسكو
فقد كشفت التقارير والمراسلات التي اعدها
شوقالي عن ضلوعه في تنسيق تواصل على اعلى
المستويات بين موسكو وسيف الاسلام القذافي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رساله سريه ومثيره حملها شوقالي من سيف
الاسلام القذافي الذي طلب ايصالها الى
موسكو
يقول شوقالي ان سيف القذافي لديه بعض
الادله التي تدين قاده وسياسيين معروفين
في فرنسا واوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ويدعون الى التفكير معا في كيفيه استخدام
هذه المعلومات
يضيف شوغالي ان لدى سيف ادله مكتوبه على
حصول الرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق نيكولاسركوزي
على اموال من معمر القذافي وان هناك صله
بالقاضي الذي يحقق في القضيه بفرنسا
وفقا لسيف الاسلام فانه في عام 2017
وبمساعده سركوزى تلقى الرئيس الفرنسي
الحالي ايمانويل ماكرون اموالا الليبيه
عبر وسطاء جزائريين
وهو الامر الذي يشعره الان بحرج كبير
عرض سيف ايضا امتلاكه وثائق اخرى تتعلق
بتقديم عائله القذافي اموالا لشخصيه نافذه
في اوكرانيا
بينها يوليا تموشنكو رئيسه الوزراء
السابقه في اوكرانيا
يقول شو قال في رسالته ان سيف لديه
مستندات تدعم التحويلات المصرفيه الى
حسابات تموشنكو ويضيف اتصل مؤخرا ممثل
الرئيس الاوكراني الاسبق بترو بوروشنكو
بافراد من جماعه سيف الاسلام وعرض عليهم
شراء هذه المستندات
كما افصح سيف الاسلام في رسالته السريه
الى الروس بان عائله القذافي تبرعت كما
قال باموال للحمله الانتخابيه للمرشح
الديمقراطي الامريكي السابق جون كيري وان
بحوزته ايصالات من بعض قاده الحزب
الديمقراطي الامريكي الذين تلقوا الاموال
في لندن
بعد عام وثمانيه اشهر من الاعتقال تم
الافراج عن مكسيم شوقالي وسامر سعيفان
فيما وصف بصفقه سياسيه
كيف تغير الحال للافراج كانت في تلك
الفتره في وسطات كثيره كان وزير الخارجيه
سيد محمد السياله
بدل جهد في محاوله تخفيف التوتر ووصل الى
ان اطلاق سراحهم بدون اي مقابل طبعا بدون
اي شيء ربما يخفف التوتر شوي
في عمليه تحرير من الاسر شارك عدد من
الاشخاص دبلوماسيون وسائل الاعلام اخبروني
انها كانت اتفاقيه لم يكن هذا نتيجه عمل
عسكريين والحكام الجدد
ارتكبوا اخطاء كبيره جدا في التعامل مع
روسيا لم يكن هناك تعامل على مستوى التحدي
ولم يتم التعامل مع ملف شغالي
بالطريقه
المطلوبه يعني سبب هذا الاعتقال ازمه مع
روسيا اين تم هذا الاعتقال
في طرابلس
[موسيقى]
يه يعني ولكن
مع انتهاء الجدل الذي اثرته قضيه الاعتقال
والتحقيق والتسليم بقي السؤال الابرز اذا
ما كانت صفحه التدخل الروسي في ليبيا طويت
مع انتهاء قصه شوقالي
هو
شو قال يتحصل على المعلومات التي يريد
وحقق بعض النتائج وهو موجود وبالتالي ان
المهمه التي جاء من اجلها شغالي عمليا
ظهرت نتائجها في مشهد الترشح للانتخابات
الاخيره هنا في ليبيا
من الاهداف الواضحه لشقالي قبل وصوله
وكانت واضح عنده وانجزها هو ان يخرج سيف
لان المشهد لم يخرج قبل ان يخرج السيف
كانت الناس بتقول لا مش موجود سر مات
خرج مش عارف ايش فكان
استراتيجيه الروسيه بكل وضوح ان يخرج سيف
للعلم ربنا افتح بيننا وبين قومنا بالحق
وانت خير الفاتحنا
ظهر سيف الاسلام المطلوب للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كمرشح للانتخابات الليبيه التي
كان من المقرر انعقادها نهايه عام 2021
لكن ترشحه اصطدم بعقبات قانونيه فضلا عن
تعثر الانتخابات وتاجيلها على وقع انقسام
سياسي ليبي مستمر
لكن الحديث عن دور روسيا في الميدان
الليبي مازال متواصلا
روسيا لديها مصالح استراتيجيه في ليبيا
ولهذا هي تواجدت في ليبيا وربما روسيا
لديها مصالح استراتيجيه في قاره افريقيا
عندما نسمع عنه يعني
ان تكون موجوده في
القواعد الليبيه ثلاث قواعد قلنا قائد
القرضابيه وقاعده زفره وقاعده في الجنوب
يعني لم تعترف بروسيا على الاقل في
الاعلام او امامنا لكن في شركه
هل هناك حرج سيد شوجالي في ان تتحدث روسيا
صراحه عن وجودها العسكري في ليبيا
يعني
اعتقد ان روسيا ليس لديها ما تخشاه واذا
كانت قواتها موجوده فانها قادره على قول
ذلك
بعيدا عن الاعلام وثق مكسيم شوقالي جانبا
اخر من ادواره
فقد كشفت وثائقه السريه انه خلال
اللقاءاته مع سيف القذافي
تمت مناقشه تعاون امني وعسكري روسي سري
على ان تدخل الطواقم الروسيه من السودان
في هذا التقرير الذي ارسله الى موسكو قال
شوقالي ان سيف الاسلام اكد استعداد نائب
وزير الداخليه فرج قعيم توقيع اتفاقيه مع
شركتنا في السودان في اي وقت ومكان
يناسبنا
وسيكون باستطاعتنا الاسبوع القادم مقابله
رئيس قسم المشتريات بوزاره الدفاع لمناقشه
القيام باتفاقيه المماثله
ويضيف شوغالي بدات جماعتنا في السودان
بدراسه القضايا اللوجستيه وجماعه سيف
الاسلام على استعداد لاستقبالهم على مدارج
مناسبه في مدينتي بني وليد وقدامس وكذلك
على مدارج رمليه قرب مدينتي الزنتان
وترهونه
اللافت ان سيف الاسلام ابلغ الروس باعداده
قائمه بالقاده الميدانيين الذين يدعمونه
وحددهم بالاسم والمناطق التي ينتمون لها
كما انه استعد لترتيب لقاءات لفريق شوقالي
معهم
امام كل هذه الاتهامات حرصت روسيا الرسميه
في اكثر من مناسبه خلال السنوات الاخيره
على نفي اي وجود رسمي للقوات الروسيه في
ليبيا
[موسيقى]
من الملفات السريه التي حصلنا عليها
واحتفظ بها شوقالي في جهازه الخاص ملف
يكشف اسرار التدخل الروسي في افريقيا
توثق هذه الملفات مثلا صور لقاءات شوقالي
وادارته لحملات انتخابيه اعلاميا وماليا
لصالح احزاب سياسيه محدده في مدغشقر عام
هذا الملف واحد من ملفات كثيره
واطلعنا عليها حيث اماطت اللثاما عن دور
الروسي مثير في دول افريقيه عده
[موسيقى]
خلال لقائنا معه في هذا التحقيق حرص
شوقالي على اظهار دوره البحثي والاجتماعي
وتجنب الحديث عن ادواره الخفيه وخاصه
الامنيه والعسكريه
توثق هذه المقاطع المصوره مشاركه الرجل في
الحرب الروسيه الجاريه حاليا على اوكرانيا
والتي تنشط فيها مجموعات فاجنر بقوه
مؤخرا ادرج الاتحاد الاوروبي اسم مكسيم
شوقالي على قائمه العقوبات الى جانب
شخصيات الروسيه اخرى مرتبطه بشركه فاجنر
التي يتزعمها
[موسيقى]
انا في التقدير بان دور الروسي
يعني تتحدث عن دوله عظمى
ولها مشروعه في المنطقه
هذا المشروع مرتبط بالتنافس مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في شمال افريقيا
وفي الشرق الاوسط بشكل عام وتتحدث عن
تنافس
عن الطاقه والنفط والغاز
وتتحدث ايضا عن الحضور في افريقيا ودول
الساحل والصحراوي وانا في تقديري ان ليس
هناك مشروع
يضاهي المشروع الروسي في ليبيا انا اعتقد
ان هناك اي حل ممكن ان ياتي بوجود تدخلات
اجنبيه هل يجب ان يكون بين الليبيين
ليستشعروا هذه الخطوره ويحاولوا انهم يكون
فيهم مصالحه حقيقيه تكون في اعدام
انتقاليه جبر للضرر وبعد ذلك تكون
انتخابات توافقيه وليس كما يجري الان نخرج
من هذا المازق والا سنبقى نحن بيادق
تحركنا اياد المخابرات الاجنبيه
[موسيقى]
من هنا بدات وانتهت فصول اعتقال الروسي
مكسيم شوكلي ومساعده في سجن عتيقه الذي
يشرف على تامينه وحمايته جهاز الردع في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس لكن ذلك لم يغلق
ملف الدور الروسي في ليبيا قواعد عسكريه
وحضور لقوات فاجنر ومحاوله للتلاعب في
تناقضات المشهد السياسي هنا دور كشفت احدى
صفحاته مع القبض على شقلي
وما خفي اعظم
[موسيقى]